all right what do you got for me tonight
William can you hear me yeah
okay I don't know I I can see the uh the
audio feed but I hope you can hear me
um so I just watched Joe Rogan's show
and he read an interesting statistic
that uh in the US in North America like
only uh like uh two-thirds of the guys
refers to sell to themselves as uh
single but only one third of women refer
to themselves as single so I want to
know if you find it interesting and what
it tells you about the dating
Marketplace yeah I was gonna save this
maybe for a future podcasts and deal
with it then but we can talk about it
right now briefly uh so there's a study
that that came out that basically says
that
um only one third of men are essentially
sexually active and more than two-thirds
of women are sexually active so so that
correlates exactly yeah so so you would
think that if so many women are sexually
active and so few men are that they're
sharing men right
so that means that men are dating more
than one women simultaneously so the
higher value guys would you know we
could postulate that the higher value
guys are dating multiple women and these
women are therefore sharing the higher
value guys which is why
they're reporting so few men being
intimate and so many women being
intimate and let's be honest we know
this is true throughout history anyway
like
um the vast majority of men have not
passed down their seed they did not
reproduce their their DNA was a
biological dead end right like
um I can't remember what the numbers
were but something like 80 percent of
men throughout history have have not
reproduced and passed on the seed uh but
something like 80 percent of women have
right so that means that these women are
having children with
um men that they're sharing essentially
so it's very consistent with that the
other thing too though is that I think
we're in a different time where the
definition of like single isn't quite
clear you know what I mean because
that's what the survey was right like
are you single or you know are you
seeing somebody and women will will say
yeah like I'm seeing somebody but they
may not know that the somebody that
they're seeing is seeing a bunch of
other people or vice versa you know as
well too because the definitions and the
lines that work consistent 30 40 years
ago are totally different today right
like we live in the most promiscuous
time in history so exactly exactly
that's that's completely right in the
last sentence yeah so there's a lot yeah
so there's a lot to unpack with that I
mean I I I'd like to see how they
conducted the study I mean I'll I'll
take some time and I'll try to dive a
little bit more in the details and you
know get into it but yeah I've I've seen
the same thing that you're talking about
it's it's been covered around the
internet now would you say it's uh the
maybe the beginning of a downfall for
the west or no
because of that the beginning of the
downfall is like the downfall is
happening so let's be honest like we're
not on society's not on a rise in my
opinion the downfall's been happening on
you know for a while
in the chat you guys let me know when
you think the downfall began
um you know was there a moment was there
something was there a event history was
there legislation was there some law
that passed
um I think a lot of the guys out there
that are really tuned in and might have
even spent some time consuming some
content
um around repealing the 19th Amendment
have you have you heard this argument
repealing the launch the internet in the
amendment not really I don't know what
the 19th Amendment specifically States
some people will say in the chat right
now like I'm seeing birth control pop up
hormonal birth control you know it would
have been a significant contributor to
the decline but I think one of the
arguments that makes the most sense is
repealing the 19th because
apparently this amendment and I don't
know when this was made I think it was
like the early 1900s maybe the late
1800s allowed women to enter the voting
system and the voting system in the past
comprised of people that had
um assets like had land like real estate
like you couldn't vote unless you had
land and you paid taxes so if you didn't
have land you didn't pay taxes your
opinion didn't matter and but rich but
Rich if you don't support illegal
immigrants voting without ID then you
are a fascist bigot got it but this is
this is where we are today but we're
talking about this 19th Amendment which
is here let me pull it up on the
internet real real quick
up since 1920 in the in the live chat
let me just do a quick Google search uh
when was the
19th Amendment passed we we progressed
approved by the senate in June 4th 1919
and ratified August 1920. so moth's
right well done with your American
history my friend thank you so in 1920
they passed an amendment in legislation
to allow uh people that didn't own real
estate or contribute to the tax system
from what I understand to vote I might
be butchering the details of that I mean
I'd have to dive into it specifically
but I would say that that where where we
pivoted and and said look people that
had skin in the game that did work that
own land that paid taxes you know were
able to cast a vote and decide what
happened with the taxpayers money
because today we live in an environment
where people can cast a vote that aren't
citizens that don't even live here you
know like we've seen people have ID that
don't even have it that can decide what
happens with taxpayers money so you can
have a flood of people come in that
never contributed to a tax system that
don't own land that don't pay property
taxes may not have ever had a job
offer an opinion on what to do with
taxpayers money which is why the
direction we've headed in is really you
know turned into like a socialist sort
of you know environment where people
with no skin in the game or making
decisions about what happens with the
money that I make when they put nothing
into the system and then they make
decisions to take more of my money
unilaterally without my consent so I
don't think the decline has been
happening the last couple years it seems
like this decline started a long time
ago in in my there was a whole episode
of John Oliver where he was talking how
people who believe that you should show
ID to vote are bigots and racists well
that's what they do when you know when
they don't get their way they just throw
a little hissy fit and they have a spaz
and they make up stuff and they like the
these authoritarians automatically
default to big tree races
islamophobe this is what Justin Trudeau
did when all the truckers went to Ottawa
right he called and the funny thing was
was a lot of the truckers that that went
to Ottawa were Sikhs like a lot of the
Canadian truckers we have here are like
like cultural seeks like they were
setting up tents and and giving food out
to everybody but he was calling them all
racist bigots
um
xenophobes islamoph like every phoband
you know how the like this is a system
that they use because they don't have an
argument so they just point and sputter
like like cowards anyway
does that make sense yes and uh what you
said about that exactly you remember how
there were a few articles here and there
about you in the shower picture and
you're never in your eel in a negative
light you read something in from Swedish
newspaper have you noticed how those
articles that depicted you or anybody
else they never comment on any argument
they just call your misogynist
there's never I've been doing this for
almost 10 years now man I I don't even
read news articles you know sometimes
people send stuff to me I don't even
bother translating I I don't care it's
always the same thing it's always yeah
but it's interesting it's interesting
how they never want to dismantle any of
your arguments because there's clear
arguments yeah they can't exactly your
arguments are almost always right they
don't even want to mention them they
just call your misogynist and how long
have I have you know been running this
podcast show and and how many questions
have I had they never call in they never
want to argue with me they'd never have
anything that they want to say all they
do is I hide in the shadows like a
little coward and they write their
little blogs with your little tweets
because that's that's what they do okay
I want to let other guys speak so
absolutely guys if you have a better
solution thanks will let me pull you out
guys if you have a better solution to
something that I've talked about you
think I'm wrong come on the show let's
hear what your better solution is tell
me I'd love to hear it let's do it I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out